cherry bread doesn't taste good with the
chocolate that they put in there i'll
[ __ ] with it joey you [ __ ] with anything
anything church is that [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] with that is this seasoned vomit i
mean i'm gonna try it
what's that big crazy konbini console
come on
that wasn't my idea that was gone that
you i know you've been hanging out with
arkey too much because that was the most
um american sounding [ __ ] i've ever
heard yeah that was like that was like
the hard seed
dude that is like actually the most
offensive thing you can say to industry
pov you're a youtube channel waving
goodbye tomorrow
so what are we doing today what's the
theme of today's episode yeah well the
theme of today's episodes
is japanese convenience stores i didn't
just say kombini in the intro for shits
and giggles like
we're going to be talking about
kombini's as it's called in japan
because
japan i feel is the only country where
the word convenience
in the word convenience store actually
you know means what it means i i think
there's a lot of places in asia where
asia where convenience stores are very
convenient but definitely as someone
who's traveled around
japan's up there it's still different
yeah
japan's up there some of the best
convenience stores in the world
absolutely and you've seen all those
videos those youtubers with the
you know kevin macleod or whatever the
[ __ ] he's called copyright free music
playing in the background being like
these are my favorite 10 kombini snacks
that's not what we're doing today we're
going to crack open the conbini halls
yeah the comedy we're just going to
crack open a bunch of beers just start
eating [ __ ]
how just saying words part of this is we
want to represent our team because i am
team 711
he is team lawson and he's team family
martial i just think lawson
is built different they've just figured
it out like family mart okay honestly
like i could
7-eleven i respect the choice family
mart you're actually just like you have
seriously i i agree family martial
is the clown pick right here we are we
are
global conglomerates we have not just
taken over japan
we are freaking everywhere in asia and
that's why they've been tainted by all
the other countries and i'm going to
prove
why today 7-eleven is the biggest my
views there's more than these three
convenience stores in japan there's like
the smaller ones like mini stop
daily yamasaki i think i [ __ ] with daily
yamazaki do you
i have everyone i know i i think i asked
chris i'm like do you like daily
yamazaki and chris was like no [ __ ]
chris is the whitest man alive what does
he know uh he's like me
that's why i can trust his opinion so
finally another one
i need another white british man opinion
what is this good no
[ __ ] all right whenever i go to like
daily yamazaki one of the smaller chains
it's like going to
[ __ ] audis or iceland you never know
you never see these convenience stores
now if you don't know anything about
convenience stores they are pretty much
found in every
100 meters yeah literally
every every block of land there's at
least one convenience yeah literally
when you like look into houses to rent
one of the selling points
is literally the meters away from the
nearest convenience store
when you're looking at listening for
houses that's that's how much they care
about convenience and if you live in
tokyo they'll most
hundred percent be like three within
your vicinity
yeah yeah absolutely um and even when
you go rural areas you're driving around
there'll be nothing and then
suddenly there's a corner you'll just
see this perfect immaculate 7-eleven
just there yeah and
it's great because it's not like a gas
station where you're like yeah [ __ ]
god i gotta get with those hot dogs that
are probably gonna give me salmonella
yeah i'm probably not gonna like this
it's legit good food so yeah we've
picked a bunch of items today that we
all kind of like
yeah uh that we could find because
sometimes the items aren't available we
we
pick the items that we we normally buy
when we go to our convenience store of
choice
and then we got our intern to buy a lot
of other random [ __ ]
from convenience stores just to show to
you guys what comfort zone a little bit
yeah going out of our comfort zone
just to show you what is available at
japanese combinations yeah we definitely
haven't tried all the things we're going
to talk about today so
kind of a learning experience also if
you're an audio only listener this is
just going to be eating asmr
this is very this is going to be the
closest to the figure episode that we've
released
um in a while where if you're an audio
only listener i apologize
um but yeah shall we just kind of jump
right into it
now i i think i know what i want to
start off with because this is the
debate
that i think started this i episode idea
which is fried chicken right now i don't
care about
how good the rest of the combini food is
how i judge companies
is the fried chicken right right okay
because when i moved to japan you know
we we've we think that
a lot a lot of americans you know they
they would like to
stand their fried chicken but a lot of
the best fried chicken i've had has come
from asia
and combini fruit fried fried chicken is
way too [ __ ] good it it it should be
illegal to make fried chicken
taste this good it's like restaurant
quality yeah yeah yeah so
when you go to the combini there'll be
hot food sections right where you can
get various amounts of hot food but the
fried chicken is like the selling point
they'll often have a whole section
probably the first thing you'll see yeah
and it normally comes in as the
gentleman will show you it comes in this
little pouch like this
right but it does it doesn't come in the
pouch it comes it's on display on like a
heater
but they put it in a pad and then they
put it in a pouch and what you can do
is you just rip off half half the pouch
unless you're a lawson
and you have to open it from the top
left i don't mind that i don't mind
squeezing it out this is the lawson
fight look at that look at that man is
that
family look convenient okay convenience
store points down because look how
convenient yeah exactly look at the
convenience of this look at that look
at that where's the [ __ ] seasoning on
that there's nothing on there okay
i'd like to just give a huge disclaimer
i'm personally not a huge fan
i think i'm like one in a million where
i almost never buy the fried chicken at
convenience stores
right because i don't really fried
chicken to begin with
now this is the the standard just pepper
and salt fried chicken but in lawson's
you can get like
a ton of different variations they have
one that is like it's like uh
it's like chinese sweet and sour one
and it's like black and i don't know why
it doesn't look good at all but it's
[ __ ] amazing
i i i don't know that just i've i've
never tried it but it just
it just because it's it's a it's a
literal black chicken
and it looks like someone it looks it's
it's like someone took a chicken and
just dunked it
in um squid oil that's what it looks
like what i think we should do is we
should cut up three pieces
you should trade pieces okay we should
we should trade
we get like napkins galore by the way
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna take the knife
and then
i'm gonna cut up three pieces now here's
the thing these chick
these chicken right now they're not
gonna look at peak condition because we
had to microwave these
normally they're crispy they're nice and
crispy fresh
and hot fresh out the oven it's got two
pieces so you guys can take it i'll just
take this okay
fan [ __ ] testing there you go there's
two pieces of you boys and also if
you're not really into like a whole
breast that's fine because a lot of them
also have like the like nuggets
like substitute thank you all right here
i'm i'm gonna hand these over to you
i'm gonna show you the shot all right
let's this is like the last supper but
family matter
we're sharing we're not sharing the
bread we're sharing the chicken i'll
show you if you will do me the honor
okay grab one of these i'll try it let's
should try the family more chicken first
okay let's let's let's let's let's let's
go bottom
let's start with you know what the
crispiness that looks good the color
looks good i'm down for it that was yeah
that's very wet though look at the green
it is
like the family one has almost left the
puddle
it's you this is actually like kind of
i'm gonna eat it yeah
like you look you can tell this is
family mart chicken
because it's the oh it's like compared
to the seven chicken this one ain't
this one this one can't be white because
it's gonna stain the white one
it's gonna go straight it's gonna go
straight through so i'm gonna i'm gonna
it is very fatty and very greasy like i
feel like there's no breast
um you know what i mean it's it's not
good
obviously if you know i'm in the middle
of nowhere i mean i'm in a hokkaido
i want a beer and a fried chicken it's
going to do the job
but when there's lawsons and and you
know
again i will happily take this over
fried chicken to begin with yeah
okay my problem with family mart fried
chicken is that
it tastes like death you know sometimes
when you're eating and you realize
wait a minute i'm eating a dead animal
right now that is what family mart
chicken tastes like
it feels like they inject it with stuff
i feel like that's a yeah let's try a
7-eleven one there shall we okay
okay this is this which one's the
7-eleven uh it'll be this one this color
there's this
slightly orange one yeah now it's pretty
good
the reason the reason i stand 7-eleven
and the reason
it's my favorite one it's close to that
fried chicken this one's also quite
fatty though it's fatty enough where
it's less than the family art chicken
it's the perfect amount you know you
know when you
you know when you want a beer and you
just want to eat something healthy this
is the perfect amount of oil
and unhealthiness that doesn't make you
feel like you're eating death it it
still makes you feel like you're eating
like something that you shouldn't be
enjoying every day
it's it's a bit of a it's i have to say
i think in terms of the seasoning they
season the
out of all of them this like with
lawson's they have
way more choice in the chicken seasoning
like there's like the spicy i i do think
this is gonna be the weakest one out of
like that the choices that lawsons have
i'm not trying to like you know about
myself in the corner but like
i'm just saying like out of everything
7-eleven just just
just does the basic fried chicken the
best has the best seasoning doesn't it
doesn't need anything fancy no spicy
chicken
it's just pure here's what fried chicken
should taste like
salt and pepper seasoned perfectly the
right amount of oil
it is the best fried chicken yeah let's
try this lawson one because i've
realized immediately that
in terms of the thickness of chicken
this is probably the thickest it's a
thick
yeah this is like you're getting good
chocolate that's like a problem this is
a proper amount of here's the chicken
and here's the that could be a candy do
that's so good yeah exactly it honestly
tastes like a tandy as well
for the right amount of juicy actually
you know what i think that might be my
favorite right
it tastes more like a chicken tender
than a like a breast
that's like the closest to kfc for
something yeah i mean i agree
i think it needs more seasoning yeah
that's what i mean like take that
chicken
right and actually put like a [ __ ] ton
of seasoning on it make it spicy because
that's the best that's that's the reason
i stand the 7-eleven chicken
it is it is like i'd say there's less
fat
than the 7-eleven chicken but the
7-eleven chicken just has the best
seasoning
and why why do we eat fried chicken it's
because of the seasoning like
you know 11 secret herbs and spices like
imagine
imagine buying kfc chicken and then all
the skins off no one would want to eat
that [ __ ] let's be honest that's the
you eat it because of the skin because
of the seasoning on the fried chicken
so i will go you know
let's write let's write one two three i
would say i personally would say
lawson seven eleven family mart i'd say
the same for me personally
i'd say i'd say you saw a little more
bias yeah yeah
i'd say seven eleven lawsons family mart
right at the bottom we can all agree
that family martial
in this case that's the third opinion in
the room joey i suppose you've put it
over the edge for lawson's right i would
i would have to give a point to lawson
just because
the seasoning for 7-eleven is good but i
i think it's like too much seasoning
yeah yeah uh they also do nuggets now
these are the basic kind which i i you'd
never catch me finding i just i don't
know
i want a spice there's like there's a
hot version and i think there's a cheese
version
yeah i don't [ __ ] with the cheese
versions because it's like injected
cheese
i don't trust that cheese should be on
top it should never be injected right
there's some things that should be
injected and cheese isn't one
of the vaccines check yeah medicine
medicine
check and uh these have been microwaved
because we've heated them up but uh
yeah they don't look too great not gonna
lie you guys want to try and nugget
the color on this chicken is kind of
tragic looking honestly
i did eat one before recording something
this looks actually
this is the most depressing chicken you
know what this looks like this looks
like
like this is like frozen yeah yellow
this is it was once frozen and i just
defrosted it it's it's like it does it
lacks
any kind of color that makes it look
that wouldn't make it look oh yeah
oh no that ain't good no they had to
slime down walson
711 family mod and then whatever the
[ __ ] i just said okay
that was worse than the family mart
chicken
i said the family mart chicken tastes
like death oh my god
that was this looks this tastes right
out the freezer yeah
oh my god you know what this tastes like
this tastes like can you show can you
put it like stab it and show it to the
camera
okay this look at that look at that this
for real tastes like
the skin is like dying to get off it
this is like one of those kadages you
order at a really really cheap
yeah it's like it's like 50 yen friday
50 yen for one yeah
yeah yeah yeah that ain't chief man the
fight but i mean honestly you can't
really go wrong unless you go family
mart
yeah i i would say the reason that
i mean we okay so where we live right
now we live right next to a family mart
and we live right next to a lawsons
unfortunately we don't live next to a
7-eleven
and that's a shame for me because some
of my best food items like the fried
chicken
and like some of the other things i'm
going to show off today is from 7-eleven
that's why like every time you see a 711
it's like an event right now oh
definitely it's like a random encounter
i'm like yo i can get the fried chicken
right now i'll be right back
i just had lunch but finna grab a friend
be right back boys
they also have a bunch of it's not just
these they have tons of other hot food
items they have like
it's like a pizza bread with like
fillings like folded up and then they
microwave it well and the other one that
i have right here well no the one i have
here is uh like a cushy
like uh skewered meat oh i have that as
well oh okay yeah these are like the
snack ones they have like like
me again i don't think i've ever ordered
these before but
they look like that that's that just
looks like a yakiniku yeah
i have never ordered it's yakitori also
yeah
i have never ordered this i've never
ordered this size i'm just gonna get
some of that
i don't have a yakitori you don't well
you can charge something i'll try
something
here honestly these don't look like you
look at you look at these on camera
and they don't look any different from
each other at all i couldn't tell which
one the lawsons
uh grab one of those yakitori is and i
can't tell which one is the family mate
yakitori
i've never gotten the yakitori uh which
is like skewered
like barbecued skewed meats right do you
feel like i'm playing with fire you know
what i mean
because these both of these the color of
them
the coloring just there is no coloring
at all don't go to a like any kind of
convene store to get yakitori there's
plenty of amazing yakitori restaurants
all over tokyo it's so cheap as well
normally you can buy per
skewer yeah it's like you know some of
the cheaper places like 30 in a skewer
i'll try the family mart one first okay
let's try the family one that's awful
that is so bad that is bad that is bad
okay
i think i think this has to be fresh
it's because we microwaved these yeah
yeah
this what it tastes like is they
didn't know how to flavor this so so
they just put as much salt on this as
possible yeah this is salted like
[ __ ] this is salt and oil what i'm
tasting right now is just
very salty oil i just stabbed into the
lawson and it like
squirted like straight up squirted oil
all right let me try this let's try them
awesome let me try the lawson's one hmm
i don't know they're just both as bad as
each other yeah they're not that good
yeah
that's pretty fun bottom lane don't go
to a convenience store to get yakitori
lots of amazing izakayas and restaurants
to go to for that
yeah i'm trying to i'm trying to chew
this and swallow this i feel like we
need a drink to go along with this
amazing food
ashley get us a drink have we talked
about ashley before in this podcast
we talked about him on the livestream
that we did but yes
we had we now have a intern
we hired uh our new intern ashley uh
what he did was he sent
a full cv to us
what did no ashley
what it what do you actually have a beer
so i can wash this down because sorry
oh no oh no
oh no at least at least he did us a
favor and got the mini ones do you want
to explain what this is
yeah so this is uh ozeki's one cup sake
which is essentially the like trailer
trash
level of sake that you can get at the
convenience stores
imagine if budweiser try to make a cheap
version of budweiser
and this is what you would this is the
blue lightning of sake
right so how much does one of these cost
these cost like a dollar a pop right
it's like 100 yen yeah yeah yeah
200 okay 250 yen that's too much for
this yeah
so that this is this costs about two
dollars it's a
literally a jar of sake and we all know
how much i love sake yeah from the
episode
honestly i have none of us have tried
this right i've never i've never tried
this either so i'm not even a big fan of
sake
i like it's like wine right like i need
the right food for it and this is not
the right food
if you calculate the uh the price per
milliliter
this is actually more expensive than one
chris brought us so
actually if it's two 250 yen yeah pretty
well yeah
well it doesn't smell horrible well it's
sac it never smells of anything much
it doesn't it doesn't smell too bad i
mean it smells like sake what does bad
sake smell like a bad sake will smell
sour
like you'll know why why okay that why
what that's like having milk and being
like
this this smells this smells sound legit
like
you wanna throw this away yeah legit
like i've had bad sake before and it's
it's sour it's it's like sour milk but
like
sake it's it's horrible all right well i
guess we gotta try this huh
so she all do at the same time yeah she
is gentleman
okay successful podcast i hope yes all
right let's give it a shot shall we
oh god that's actually no that's not
bad at all what that i was not i was
expecting a burn
or a bad aftertaste that's not
you know what i can't believe i'm saying
this i'm kind of [ __ ] with this like
it actually tastes alright you want mine
come on
i don't [ __ ] this man just cannot
drink saga this is actually
i was expecting it to feel like i'm
drinking petrol
yeah that's what i was expecting as well
japan
this is the cheap alternative to like
getting pissed in japan
i can see why all these like you know
like old people go
into uh you know 7-eleven or wherever
buy one of these and just chill at the
front of the seven left yeah
i would probably be there as honestly
this is why we like uh this is why
kombini's are great because sometimes
you buy something and it's
way better than you expect to buy at a
convenience store this sake you taste
way too good too for something that just
came out of a 250 yen convenience store
sake okay
it's actually not bad wow it doesn't
really taste of much that's why i mean
it's easy to drink yeah
it's really easy to drink because a lot
of like cheap sake usually has like a
very
harsh honestly it's less i think it's
less offensive than the one that chris
wrote the other day actually this
actually tastes better than on the
christmas yeah yeah yeah
so chris [ __ ] us over thanks so much
i'm still going to stay what i'm saying
is the milliliter that's
a price ratio but god you have two more
hot food outlets i do
i do i don't know what ashley has bought
me but let's let's have a look okay so
the first one
looks like a karaoke what the which
potato yeah yeah there's so what a
karaoke is it's kind of just like a
potato katsu right that's that's the
right way to describe it
so sometimes oh that is that is very
oily
that is
that is literally see-through that is
that is the same that is like the
simpsons episode yeah
simpsons episode right here so what this
is i don't know what kind of crocodile
should we want to crack that open on the
table
yeah that's all right let's let's let's
do it oh okay it's not a
karaoke what is it oh okay so it's not a
karaoke it's katsu it's like minced meat
katsu basically
okay i've never had this so essentially
you know what this is this is literally
a deep-fried hamburger
this is what this is this is literally
what this is it's a
it's a deep-fried hamburger this is look
at that this this is this is a
basically a hamburger this is a smell
you know what it smells like it reminds
me like pies in the uk
it does a little bit yeah it's like a
minced pie it has it has a very pie
smell
oh my god i don't know if you can see
this on camera but the oil
has seeped the oil has seeped through to
the table doesn't really taste of
anything
like meat and grease that's all i tell
you
there's like no seasoning oh my god this
tastes
like how how do you know what actually
you don't know
how do you eat something and just have
zero opinion about the taste
right yeah just nothing this literally
tastes like cardboard
because there's no taste in it at all
like you'd
like you'd expect some kind of burger to
have some kind of seasoning on it this
tastes like batter
yeah granted i've had a really good
mensch katsu and this is definitely a
weak sauce like
weak sauce compared to what i had what
else did you get okay
okay you wanted you want to see this
yeah sure it's a spring roll
you ever all gotten the spring roll from
look at that this i i do not stand this
look at that
okay let's i'm gonna cut this up you
know this is this is
this you know it's not good when you're
cutting a spring roll and it turns flat
it's a soggy spring roll right you know
wow
i i don't like spring rolls in general i
i yeah i don't like spring rolls they're
way too oily for me
it's not bad actually that's not bad at
all how's it taste how does it taste
it's quite fatty somehow like very fatty
you know what it's like
it tastes like a dim sum yeah oh a
little bit it's like the kind of
oil yeah it's like an oiliness of a dim
sum
it's like you know you know when you
because in the uk we have these like
party platter things
yeah you get from ice that's what it
looks like yeah so you thought you were
just gonna get a bite of just pure like
pastry whatever was it pastry is that
what it is oh yeah i think it's pastry
pastry and then just maybe like a crumb
of meat yeah and like that's normally
how it is that's why i hate spring rolls
but
that one was packed i you know i i i'd
get that i would actually honestly
honestly
i did not expect it to taste that good
it tastes like
yeah like you said like a mini dim sum
yeah but in a spring roll pastry yeah
um wow that was that was not the taste i
was that's
that's the point i thought they would
somehow make this one work and [ __ ] up
the spring yeah right
it's the opposite way around you
surprise us but there's there's tons of
stuff that we don't have here hot foods
like a change all the time like for
example lawson's has like
hot dogs that have like different
toppings like salsa there's like meat i
mean let's not forget as well about
the nikumans and the pizza monsters
right yeah yeah i think all of the
convenience stores yeah
yeah what's what's it called just like a
steamed bun yesterday so like
you can get like the chinese steamed
meat buns cinnamon all the animes
yeah honestly all like all of the meat
buns and all three of the companies are
lit
and they taste really good they taste
way too good and yeah those are really
good i i [ __ ] with the hot dogs hot dogs
are pretty [ __ ] good
what are they called the goo dogs dogs
they're called and at one point
okay so they they also go through at all
the chains they all go through seasonal
items
at one point they had like like uh mini
burritos
money burritos yeah like microwavable
burritos that were like
they're probably like proper burritos no
if if there's one food item that i think
is really hard to get in japan or one
food cuisine
mexican food it's so hard to get good
mexican food in japan you can get
any other any other food i feel like
i've had i've gone to a restaurant
and i've been like yeah this is almost
the only way you can get mexican food is
to go to like international chains that
just happen to be here right yeah yeah
and
even then like we've been to some
mexican restaurants we can get rid of
this [ __ ] we've been to some mexican
restaurants and i've always felt
underwhelmed
oh yeah it's always it's always felt
like the mexican but it's sad because
that's the best you're gonna get yeah
exactly
exactly we need more good mexican in
japan i'm putting that out there right
now because mexican
mexican food [ __ ] slaps i get really
sad because i watch on like youtube i
watch like there's like
food inside or where the [ __ ] they're
called like videos yeah the 10 best
burritos
in la and i'm like oh my god all of them
look [ __ ] amazing
um but yeah no i mean there's there's
other food items as well that are hot
like you can get actual like full meals
you can get instant ramen which is
yeah like it's like a solid like frozen
broth i'm not really sure
it's like freeze-dried it's freeze-dries
block and it basically when you
microwave it
it melts and makes a broth that's
actually like better than most of the
[ __ ] you'll get
ever in like america oh yeah yeah you
know even like some restaurants i've
been to that say ramen they're like
definitely not wrong
it's actually not bad um there's also
you can get and god has one of them
with us there's a bunch of variations uh
lawson's does a ton of like
over there's the pastas as well i
remember as well yeah the pastas are
lit pastas uh weird combinations of
pastas as well like stuff that like you
would never see
everything very very japanese twist on
italian food yeah
what's a weird combination they have
they'll have like um
[ __ ] like egg and tomato sauce or
something that like i was like
yeah sometimes they put hot dogs in
their pastas
some of the pastas literally look like a
kid's meal it's true it's true
they look like the dairyli the like
dairy meal lunch pack lunchbox
you know when you get you're a kid and
you kind of make your own like sandwich
out of the
lunchables yeah that's what they that's
like the equivalent of putting into
japanese
uh sorry italian cuisine yeah lawson's
has like a premium hot food section
which is doesn't include any of that
pasta [ __ ] right it's only japanese and
not normally fried food yeah but it's
there is udon
which is like udon is uh just like i
guess strips of
beef and then grilled and then put with
rice and you normally get like a sauce
or a mayo to dip it in
right nice and then butter which is my
favorite is just pork
like strips of pork pork on spoon
it's a pork ball or a beef we're about
to show you this episode is sponsored by
harry's
too often we're choosing between quality
or a fair price
with harry's you don't have to choose
gentlemen they give you award-winning
blades
at factory direct prices they give us
both quality and fair price
i thought that was illegal i thought
that was illegal as well now i would
have to ask boys when you got your first
harry's razor set and shaved with it
what surprised you most about the
quality of the product
well for one it comes in a lovely
cardboard box and look
at it look at the packaging on this oh
this looks clean as [ __ ] look at that
god damn you got there in your hand i
have here the body wash which melin
literally said earlier and i quote if
you're lonely
you can know what a boyfriend smells
like
i mean they're literally giving life to
dreams
for a limited time harry's is offering
their starter set plus a free body wash
for just
three dollars okay that's actually
pretty good three bucks three dollars
dot com slash trash table you can see us
live reacting to us
as we're reading it's literally the
first time i've read that that's
actually it's not actually three dollars
it's actually three dollars that's
actually really cool
and that comes with the shave cream
eraser with a very nice handle by the
way
we also have two razor heads so when the
first one runs out and i don't know what
that final thing oh it's a storage thing
for your razor that's cute
and did you know that harry delivers a
close but comfortable shave at a fair
price
only two dollars a refill that is really
fun
for what you're getting oh my god harry
believes in quality so much that they
bought their own factory in germany so
they could own
every step of the manufacturing process
that's an epic gamer move
i mean it's german so you know they're
getting [ __ ] done
but i'm sitting here and i'm wondering
how do they do it harry's team combined
a simple
ergonomic design with five sharp blades
they source their steel from sweden
and manufacture their blades in their
world-class blade factory
harry's german factory is one of the few
selected manufacturers in the world that
have mastered the technology to create a
gothic arch
the gold standard for racer blade
grinders and they have a 100 quality
guarantee
they stand behind the quality of their
blades so much that they have a 100
money back guarantee on harrys.com so
for a limited time harris says an
exclusive offer
for the listeners of this show new
customers can get the harry's starter
set and a free body wash just three
dollars at harry's dot com slash trash
taste that's over 16
value for just three dollars and you'll
get a five blade razor with a weighted
handle it's actually quite weighty
feel that gentlemen foaming shave gel a
travel cover and a travel size body wash
and i have to say
i have used the razor myself it's a very
clean shave i highly recommend it that
gothic arch
is working wonders might i say it's that
german engineering right it's an
incredibly great deal but act fast while
supplies last go to harrys.com
trash taste to redeem your offer back to
the episode okay so as the
good on that connor was talking about i
have some 7-eleven goudon
right here so not a liar doesn't look
appetizing
i have also never seen that before have
you ever seen this before it's it
honestly it [ __ ] slaps it tastes
great vertically to the camera okay
i can't show it vertically because it's
got it's got sources in it but look
what happens is that it comes it comes
with two compartments right
okay there we go juices the juices
there's a lot of juices in here so what
happens is
it's basically just grilled like what is
it grilled
beef beef strips uh in whatever juices
they
cook it in and it comes with two
compartments ah that is
that is that is hot it comes with the
rice compartment that's a common mistake
that people comes with the rice
compartment
or you can just dump it all on or you
can just take a piece at a time yeah
exactly
whatever works best you've got two
compartments you can eat it however you
like i like to dump it i'll give it a
shot
the reason the reason why they split it
up is the spices on this [ __ ] as well
yeah some uh some like heat this is just
an excuse for us to uh film our eating
our dinners right
you know we're not gonna lie you can
tell this is like super cheap because
like it's
this beef is half just fat look at that
like that is you know the reason though
why they started it
that's the good part you know the reason
why they split it up into two layers
though
so that the rice doesn't soak up yeah
yeah yeah you wouldn't want the rice
being sorry
come on okay honestly if you come to
japan try the beef bowls because the
beef bowls are
by far my favorite like 7-eleven or
whatever convener you decide well you
can go to the top three beef ball chains
oh yeah you could just go outside
they'll probably be at matsuyazukiya or
it's my favorite cheap japanese dish
throw some of that on my plate
yeah so do you get this often i get this
whenever like i'm traveling
and i just you can never go wrong with
beef balls yeah if i have to get a meal
in lawson's right they basically do like
uh katsudon
and they have like uh it's really
[ __ ] good really clean cuts it on
with just rice it's just like perfect
it's so good
and they give you like a [ __ ] ton as
well so good [ __ ] god you probably
powered that on there
i
[Music]
ratio did you actually like mayo with
mine you like mayo
will give you mayo and sometimes it's so
nice to have mayo with it i know some
people think that's disgusting but
you're really like because sometimes all
you're getting is just grease grease
grease and mayo helps like
i i always get mine with mayo yeah i
mean i like the fats i i like
but sometimes you need to like mellow it
out a little bit yeah but this man
doesn't like condiments
that's not bad actually yeah it's good
right and how much is this this is 400
yen this whole box
this is this is literally yeah this is
about four bucks and you can get an
entire meal
and it [ __ ] slaps like a one-off
that's pretty [ __ ] good yeah
like if you're desperate and you want a
good meal that's actually not bad
yeah i'm pretty surprised if you don't
man says so then it must be good
it is obviously you know if you go to
matsuya yoshinoya or whatever
they literally cook it in front of you
yeah like from honestly like this is
this is like
this is not bad if you're if you're out
about and you just want a quick meal and
you you know can't you there's no
matsuya or there's no like chain around
you
look he's going on for seconds that's
how good it is that that's that says
more than
a little fatty but yeah that's pretty
actually i'd eat this would it be good
for with uh some mayonnaise on it
yeah but a managed yeah not bad though
points to 7-eleven for that one i guess
yeah so there was tons of other hot food
that we couldn't get and also we just
don't want to waste all of it um
we don't want to throw away too much
food the staff is eating all of it don't
worry
so yeah i mean that's that's most the
hot food that we want to talk about
today yeah and the rest is just a bunch
of snacks yeah there's the
if there's one thing that all three
convenience stores have it's snacks yeah
they have way more snacks they do hot
food i think oh way way more all right
so
before we move on before we move on from
the hot foods um
so how long do you guys feel like you
can
survive on convenience store food before
you start to get bored of it
well i actually tried that out once uh
when i
was why because it was the only option i
had so
basically when i was which mean it was
the only option you had well let me let
me explain when i was working i was like
16 i was working at the ski fields in
hokkaido right right i'm in the middle
of
[ __ ] nowhere in hong kong oh in the
mountains the only thing they had
i'm 16 as well so i can't drive to the
next you can't afford a fancy meal
i can't afford fans basically i'm living
day by day with what they're paying me
right yeah yeah
and also because it's snowing [ __ ] 24
7 there right
without a car you're basically [ __ ]
like you can't walk in
you know into a snowstorm to like go to
the next town financial advisor
not even my financial advisor could save
me but so
the only thing they had around where i
was staying was a family mart
oh that's why you're a family master so
i literally
throughout that entire month i i would
want to say minimum
two meals a day every day for a month
was family mart yeah
and you know what i felt like i wanted
to die by the end of it
there's only so much like first week
you're just like all right i'm going to
try that bento i'm going to try that
bento basically
i like i like fully completed the
pokedex of like family my food
yeah i was like yeah i tried everything
and once i did finish everything i was
like
i highly regret that i did that because
i feel so
[ __ ] unhealthy right now because the
thing is when you come
when you come to japan for the first
time and you see how
just how much choice of meals there are
in every convenience stores especially
for me
coming from england where the only
choice i have is
the tesco's meal deal don't don't come
on don't don't talk ill of like the best
thing that we have about our country
but there's in terms of like let's say
packageable
lunches or meals that you can get away
with
pastries that's kind of about it really
we do have something you've got
sandwiches you got i think we all have
the problem with the uk
stuff that you can like kind of take
quickly it's all in like the same genre
and the food the thing like it doesn't
there's no there's no variety yeah yeah
and the thing is only say only
like the big super mega stores have the
hot food like the fresh
chicken food is good like sometimes you
you go to like sainsbury's it's the big
sainsburys and they have like the hot
rotisserie chickens
those actually slap but tesco's have
like the sausage like yeah like
foot long sausage that you can eat
[ __ ] amazing but those but those are
limited to like the really really big
stores
um so the good thing about convenience
stores is that all this
like everything you see is basically
homogeneous throughout basically every
convenience store you can find
there are some that are bigger that have
even more choice
of what you can buy but we are
showcasing stuff that you can buy in
basically every convenience store you
can get
living here it's sort of like you view
convenience food almost like mcdonald's
in my mind like
yeah it starts to have like a almost
it's not a mcdonald's characteristic to
the
taste of how you know it's not like it's
not all fresh it doesn't all
taste quite like something's been a
little too
healthy as they package it up yeah right
i mean there are definitely some healthy
things like there's some decent salads
there's some stuff like that and like i
mean
after the gym i think we always uh we
always just get like this just chicken
breasts salad chicken yeah so
so they have literally you have one of
them right do i have a chicken breast
joey might have one
did you did you buy a chicken breast the
only thing i have is this sauce
it's just a sausage just it's called
it's from johnsonville amazing name
it's an american brand i think so and
you can just rip it open and you start
eating it
one sausage what what what i do have
it's not a chicken breast
something similar like that but but they
literally have uh this is
this this is a a salad chicken ball i
don't know what a salad chicken bar is
what the [ __ ]
um it's like a salad in a bar with
chicken what the [ __ ]
no chicken has ever been in that shape
what is that it's like a chicken
sausage almost so normally the ones that
i get and they also have a family mart
and lawsons i don't know why they
wouldn't uh have them at some point it's
like a salad chicken
nuggets imagine literally a chicken
breast seasoned
i think the one that i always go for is
tandoori flavor
chicken tandoori it's literally just a
chicken breast just in a
vacuum sealed package that is just
vacuum sealed vacuum seal package like
this yeah you crack that bad boy open at
like three a.m
you go for a workout right you know you
want to get some protein what's the best
source of protein just eat a [ __ ]
whole chicken breast yeah
20 grams of protein boom you're talking
because normally like if
it's it's it's it makes it so convenient
because no matter what mood or no matter
what kind of food you want
they probably have it at your
convenience store if you want something
healthy
you can oh god that looks awful this
this this this this that looks
like oh show the gloss to the camera
oh my god look at that yo give me a bite
of that give me yo
let's cut that this is glossier than
some nails jesus christ
that looks
oh this feels you know what this it
feels plastic i'll try it but i'm not
gonna happen
i'm not gonna like it this looks like a
like a hot dog with extra peppers on it
honestly oh my god it tastes like a
chicken hot dog that's [ __ ] weird
okay that's just a chicken hot dog
i don't know if you were supposed to
take the skin off of those though no
no no it's a chicken hotdog i like how
they call it a
salad chicken when it's just a chicken
hot chocolate
well then japan's not not going to know
what chicken hotdog is probably
that's [ __ ] awful yeah do you know
what they call corn dogs here yeah
american dogs america dogs i mean
honestly that's a pretty [ __ ] good
name yeah
it's pretty accurate name it's like what
are the hot dogs that they eat in
america
corn dogs all right gentlemen we all
have sandwiches from our respective
stores
and i want to know which sandwich is
your go to for me it's always this one
tuna and tamago oh [ __ ] my bag got
crushed but
honestly i'm not making this look
appetizing but same joey yeah
you'll notice though the difference
between the family mart and the lawson
sandwiches with especially with the egg
yeah the egg in family mod is kind of
like sliced event yeah they slice the
eggs
fully scrambled and honestly yeah this
[ __ ] slaps this [ __ ] is honestly both of
them slap i feel and what what the [ __ ]
this guy
this this uh they didn't have the
sandwich they asked for which is just
like a katsusando
so katsusando is literally just like a
pork katsu
um just with some bread slapped on the
side and some uh katsu sauce
what the [ __ ] is i see i've always seen
so this is
just show it to the camera so i've
always seen this right you put it in
frame with us so that it's it's an okay
it's literally like a strawberry
shortcake turned into a sandwich
that looks awful can you can you crack
that open
okay okay i've always seen those because
they sell those at family mart too
i've never tried them also the genius
japanese packaging you just there's a
little slip that you pull open and boom
it's ready to go
everything falls outwards like that
isn't that amazing that's just beautiful
that is japanese engineering to define
you've got a little picnic for your
sandwiches how do you feel about uh the
lack of cross boys
it's disappointing i mean i mean look at
this right like there's something
missing
it's the bite of the crust yeah it's not
good it's beautiful
it's beautiful do you guys give a [ __ ]
if i just rip some off and hand it to
you yeah okay
so you try that egg gone that's the real
egg okay that's the look at the color
look at the [ __ ]
bright the saturation has been pumped to
ten thousand on that you know that [ __ ]
this one's got some slices in it i've
had this one oh that that feels like a
weak bread you know what i mean
they're all weak branches what are you
talking about oh god it's been dunked in
the grease
okay i i don't know how to properly
smear this
[Laughter]
oh it's cross-contaminated oh no which
which which tomato were you trying first
let's try the family one so the
one with the slices on it honestly like
what i love about japanese eggs
is that they just have the color in them
i don't know every every japanese egg
just is like it's like they took the egg
the egg yolk
put it in photoshop and turned out the
saturation it looks beautiful
it's like way too yellow for it to be
real yeah i like the egg
the problem i have with this sandwich
sorry i'm eating my mouth
was the tuna taste like [ __ ] you think
so and this found this sandwich i think
i think the tuna tastes the same
no you see what i mean honestly i i
really like the egg i like the egg to be
solid um i love the egg slices yeah yeah
i do like that all right let's try the
lawson egg sandwich then so this one is
no egg slices just
fully mashed okay what i don't like
about this one and why
i've never bought this one is because
this egg looks like runny yolk
it looks like the [ __ ] that comes out
your nose it's like runny egg yolk
definitely a lot more of like a
mayonnaise flavor in this yeah yeah yeah
now i prefer to chew on my eggs you know
what and i feel it
you know what i'll give you that one
that that like there is something about
knowing there's like an
egg slice in there that's way more
comforting i don't know i'm gonna try
and [ __ ]
dissect this this isn't working
sandwiches were just not meant to be
shared let's be honest
i'm just gonna rip it off sorry there
you go joey oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
try some real [ __ ] tuna tasting
sandwich action
can you give me some of that sandwich
honestly like when it comes to the tuna
it all tastes the same whatever what i
want to mention though
is that all the breading for all the
sandwiches in japan
it it's so fluffy it's so light and
fluffy that's why it's
some of my favorite breads i think oh my
gosh i just realized we're breaking
bread guys
like true comrades which one are we
eating first i'm the family
what's the difference there is again
there is no difference no no no i can
spot which one
that one's uh okay no that's that's
that's a little stupid
i can tell the difference ah no actually
i don't know i'm a cool sauce on this
one no no no
the bread the bread's different the
bread
the bread listen listen try it you'll
know what i'm sure i smell on the table
you'll know what i mean you're not
honestly gone like you're you're the
mediator in this one
try both of those and tell me if there's
a [ __ ] difference
different like the family mart one it's
great no no it's got weird tinge to it
let's try the last one okay so this
one's the lawson one right yeah
okay let me try both it tastes the
[ __ ] secret oh actually hold on yeah
see see what i mean
lawson one's better yeah okay i agree
the lawson one actually tastes like
it's so clean i don't know what it is
man the lawson tuna sandwich
like like it's amazing it's like like
the initial taste i i bit into both and
the initial taste was just like
okay they both taste the same and then
the aftertaste from the lawsons tuna
you actually get a taste it tastes like
fish yeah it tastes it tastes like fish
so if you like the like the taste of
fish i'd say the lawson one is better if
you don't like the taste of fish i'd say
the family might want is better yeah
i'll give that all right let's try the
now let's try this abomination
honestly there's a part of me there's a
part of me that's thinking this is going
to be good
this is my only strawberry this is this
is i've already got one strawberry as
well
honestly one thing that the sandwiches
are guilty of doing here is that they
look
loaded in the front they look like
they're filled and then you take one
bite and you realize there's nothing
they click bait
yeah it's literally it's it's literally
like the walker's crisp yeah where or
like it's
you bite into it and most of it's just
air and i found that family mart does
that the worst
family members has this sandwich right
that i used to get from valuable which
is
egg and ham i think and in the front man
it looks like it's
bursting it can't wait to get out and
you take one bite and then you realize
like
it goes from like this like it's so
thin let's give this a shot all right
that's not a sandwich honestly it's just
a cake that's just
yeah it's a dessert it's a strawberry
shortcake that's
really [ __ ] weird because you know
what it tastes like a strawberry
strawberry shortcake but then you're
just chewing bread proof that bread
works with [ __ ] anything
no i i that that tastes wrong i'm not a
fan of that i would i would rather just
eat a strawberry
that's the that's like the equivalent of
putting
a burger or like putting a patty between
two two bread
two breads uh slices and calling it a
burger
yeah yeah i've always seen those being
sold because i think they sell all of
those at like
lawson and seven have dessert sandwiches
which is just [ __ ] weird i was the
one with like uh i saw one where was
like
uh cream and lime cream no no no no no
i'm sorry uh kiwi kiwi it was kiwi
slices
yeah yeah and i was like that looks
[ __ ] wack one thing i say i will say
the whipped cream they use here in japan
it's s
tier whipped cream uh i agree i whip
cream to me doesn't really [ __ ] taste
like anything i just kind of like you
you taste japanese whipped cream and
you think it tastes like you you taste i
can i can stand that better i don't like
like you telling me that the whipped
cream did not carry what you just
ate right there because it looks like
the bread kind of carries
get out of here i have like one quarter
of a [ __ ] strawberry there's nothing
happening i used to i used to [ __ ]
despise like
all cakes and stuff like that like
strawberry shortcake i was like nah
that's some boring [ __ ] but then i had
strawberry shortcake here yeah i was
like
oh my god strawberry caught uh i i was
exactly the same strawberry shortcake
here
blew my mind because the the cake part
is so fluffy
and the cream the whipped cream japanese
whipped cream is the best i've tasted
in the world i will i will stand by that
and that's why japanese sweets taste so
good a lot of it
but talking what do we use so what are
we trying next lads
we try like the more like savory snacks
maybe like the fish and the meats next
do you guys have any of those
sure so gentlemen as you know one of the
most
um well-known food items
i was trying to say but one of the most
well-known food items from japan
is of course the jelly doughnuts aka
actually
you took me back the onigiri uh which if
you've seen if you've basically watched
any anime you've seen characters eating
onigiri
the rice balls this is this is basically
the closest we get to an actual japanese
sandwich because it's a
rice sandwich basically right this is a
wait wait
oh okay oh oh oh my god i did not
where's the seaweed where is the seaweed
the best part it's like
it's like the hot dog wrapper right yeah
the best part of a hot dog is the crunch
yeah right what is that it is a grilled
salmon onigiri
oh i have a grilled salmon one as well
okay we want also a grilled salmon
salmon onigiri so yeah as you know me
and gan actually ate onigiri and this is
actually one of them that i was eating
and it was
quite delicious as much as i was
complaining uh show business honestly
that is that is my favorite onigiri to
get so from
lawsons i've never seen that one from
i mean from all of the places gone now
lawson's
like every good big brain company has
their own
product line specifically for onigiri
they have the bit the basic [ __ ] on
igiri yeah it's like 100 yen now this
[ __ ] is like 190 yen
oh that's a premium shirt you can't even
see it that's how premium is it honestly
i i will stan
um 7-eleven hot foods and fried foods
i don't i don't understand it's honest
this is the most depressing looking
onigiri i've ever seen
i'm sorry it's it's like it's like
someone put the condom on wrong
they put the condom on sideways instead
of on top now let me gentlemen let me
show you what a good honey giri
okay actually it looks the same it's
just
it's just it's just a bigger condom no
no that's how it should look look at
that that's just the bigger condom
that's a beautiful honestly it's
beautiful because every bite you get you
get a bit of seaweed
i think here's the thing that
differentiates between a good on your
gear and bad noise
it's the rice to insides ratio 100 100
yes if there's like if the first bite
you bite into an onigiri and you
immediately hit the inside that's a good
one yeah too fair a lot of the cheap
ones or even sometimes like if they've
just filled it not not quite right that
one time you do just get like four bites
in you're like
where is the [ __ ] where's the feeling uh
i gotta ask
do you boys actually eat on a gear
anymore yes yeah i still do you do i
gave up
i do whenever i need to quit when i
whenever i literally need a quick snap
yeah i'm sure i'm just never in the mood
for a block of carbs you know what i
mean
that's the problem and like there's not
enough filling i'd rather wait and yet
you get the [ __ ] microwavable gu dogs
that's if like i want to [ __ ] i want
to pig out
i haven't had a goo dog in a long time
just like that she's dreadful
honestly because sometimes sometimes i
miss my lunch and i have like a filming
or something
and i just need to fill up my stomach as
quickly as possible and that's when i
get
just like one onigiri that lasts me
until dinner and it does everything it
needs to do what is your favorite
filling of the
year so there's different flavors that
you could have in it normally all
fish there is sometimes grilled chicken
but honestly i'm not a fan of the
don't get it like cause the good part
about the fish one is that normally like
seeps into the rest of the area yeah the
chicken one just is a ball
i'd have to say the tuna it's probably
true is my favorite as well
i actually you are holding my favorite
one which is the salmon belly
it's really really good premium uh
salmon
uh i in terms of the chicken how do you
guys feel about the onigiri where it
doesn't really have a filling
it's just kind of like the grilled
grilled rice with grilled chicken or
whatever i used to eat those when i was
little
but as i got older i was like nah i just
want i want something more like
yeah yeah yeah it feels like satisfying
yeah fake meal i don't know why
um but yeah i don't know why when i
first visited japan i [ __ ] all i ate
was like onigiri i think
everyone's like because you're like oh
my god i'm in japan i'm gonna eat the
japanese things i can't get this at home
i can get a sandwich at home yeah but
then when i started living here i'm like
yo the sandwiches are pretty [ __ ]
bomber have you tried these sandwiches
and they're like nearly the same price
what am i doing man and sandwich is
easier to eat because sometimes onigiri
falls apart if you like if you're you
know sometimes you're going to write
a bad idea yeah like i didn't give to me
i never eat onigiri as a meal like if
i'm having a lunch i never pick
onigiri as the lunch onigiri is a
convenience if i need to stuff myself
and have it not taste awful i just
realized
there's like no way for us to like share
yeah
to be fair i've never tried the family
mart branded i have never tried the
seven onigiri
i've had this one before and it's good
and i'm just gonna do a bite just to
prove that it's good again
oh look at that immediately wait like
okay how many how deep would i have to
bite draken to get the filling jay
all right i just bit a whole ton of rice
and it didn't even have any seaweed
i hit like once one millimeter of first
birth
let me give it a bite i mean how deep
this do you yeah yeah
that's i already broke into salmon yeah
look at that
mine mine like my salmon actually has
like a little bit of like soy sauce in
it so the soy sauce kind of seeped into
the rice a little bit
that's really flavorful that's good
that's nice fatty salmon this is this is
awful this is all foreign
honestly this this this is the most
depressing looking grilled simon
fix your shirt okay so we can say family
martin lawson have got their
branded onigiri damn pretty down pat
yeah if you want the best onigiri from a
uh chain i would highly recommend
i would highly recommend lawson's as
well lawson's especially the grilled
salmon belly
that is [ __ ] bomb um what other
cold or savoury snacks do you guys tend
to go over okay we have the
you don't eat that i do not eat this you
know what this is this is the seafood
sticks
that you see in every asian restaurant
and i don't know
why every asian restaurant serve this
serves these well i don't want to make
sense
measuring contest but mine's bigger
but every now and then aki asked me to
come and buy like one of these crab
sticks
why okay i tried it it's actually kind
of good i don't
like crab especially this isn't just
like crab or fish this is fish paste
cheese and cod row that sounds dreadful
oh
my god my one's got like mayonnaise like
inside of it
why it's a seafood steak spicy roast
that looks [ __ ] awful oh my god that
looks
good look at that look at that oh my god
this this is just like oh smell it smell
it that smells awful
that smells like off tuna oh it just
dribbled
smell that oh
that is like the fishiest fish smell
ever yeah you know what i'm not even
gonna open this i'm just gonna eat yours
yeah you know when you just have fish
that's been left out for a few days
um that's what this smells like it
smells like the thing is i usually [ __ ]
with the crab sticks at like uh
summer festivals and stuff like that so
i hope this is something like that
it's not good it's just it's bad not
good for home
oh god no that is
uh that is bad that's awful that is i
just prefer the normal crab stick don't
put [ __ ] in a double cheese in it i
can't even taste the cheese i don't like
it i definitely taste
okay i don't like crab sticks because i
don't mind like crabs
crab is one food that i think just
doesn't taste good processed
and crab sticks just feel like they they
feel like such
processed foods it's like canned lobster
you want canned lobster no one wants
like you gotta you gotta have with the
with the crab sticks
i used to think the same but like you go
to like a summer festival and you get
the ones that are like on the [ __ ]
grill with like the things oh yeah but
that's [ __ ] that [ __ ] is fire yeah
but it's not i
i i don't think it's the crab that
tastes good it's the fact that it's
grilled and it's got the sauce on it
and i'd rather have another it can be
good i think it's really good yeah this
video is sponsored by bok su connor what
is boxing boxing is the only japanese
snack box that partners with over 100
year old family snack makers to deliver
japan's exclusive snacks right to your
door
and i have to say i've never seen any of
these at a combini so that probably
means they're premium look at this
i love my soft cookies and this oh this
i'm going to have well boys
march is the start of the honey season
what's hanami
or the cherry blossom season so to
commemorate that
boxy orders placed in march will get a
special hanami themed pink box instead
of box's signature orange
but be quick because these stocks are
limited
it's right here first time boxy
customers will receive the seasons of
japan box so they could get a taste
of the snacks per season repeated
customers will get a themed box
every month gentlemen what kind of
snacks do you like i'm a giant sambae
fan
and this is a rather extraordinary
looking scent that's the black sesame
taiko with the kumamon
love me some sesame so i'm very down
what do you got they got i have here a
cookie joey what is this cookie oh
that's the aomori apple caramel yakoy
sable
that sounds sexy all i know about apples
all i know
is i like me my soft cookies and this
like it's a nice soft moisturizer god i
want a cup of tea best part is it's
vegetarian
yeah and jerry what's yours well my
favorite one is the stick potato super
mucho plum we talked about the
sour plums on this episode yeah so you
know me i love me my sour plum so if
there's a cell pom snack
you know i'm gonna dig that ooh that
looks nice and gentlemen i'm sure we can
all agree that ever since moving to
japan
japan's snack game is just on another
level oh yeah there's no competing
no one can travel at the moment but if
you want a taste of japan and all their
glorious snacks you can do that by
getting yourself epoxy foxy honors
japanese heritage
and artisanal makers by partnering with
them to bring authentic flavors
around the world so get 10 off save up
to 47
on your own authentic japanese snack box
from boxer using
our link be sure to use code trash taste
10 for 10
off back to the video what you got there
connor what do you got there connor
this is uh rather odd looking it's like
a [ __ ] whole deli
yes it's just a bunch of uh lots of
bacon it looks like but like
we're about to show off why japanese
bacon
is just one of the worst bacons you can
find in the world i'll try my best to
hold this up
burning myself okay so this this is this
is japanese bacon here this is a meat
platter
as you can see it is floppy and soggy
it's gonna go oh god
don't flop it around i don't know i just
want to show
off that this is not what bacon should
look like or feel like there's
two kinds of sausage and pepper bacon i
mean what are we trying
well i'll you know i'll try the one kind
of sausage i'll try the other kind then
whatever one is just cut one in half
actually yeah yeah yeah yeah
um but what else do you have there in
the meantime jerry well okay well i know
you guys have never tried this
but we have nanko ume
which is pickled plums pickled plums uh
i
you think i haven't tried that i
actually have tried that okay but
there's two different types
because for some reason sydney [ __ ]
loves pickled plums and i do not know
what's the thing literally i don't know
if this is just a stereotype
literally every female i know loves
pickles
i don't know why like if it's plum if
it's like an actual plum plum flavored
thing
yeah is it true like melon do you like
pickled plum
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying chicks
love pickled plums i don't understand
literally every japanese girl i know
loves pickled plum flavored [ __ ]
tell me what kinds of sausage you would
like to have just give me one of them
what are the different i mean this is
like a finger yeah
it's just it's basically they quickly
straight up like
it looks like a finger that's like
[ __ ] out of yoshi
that's not
there's one thing that japan just
doesn't do and it's sausages like they
just don't do them right and like
they'll they'll go around calling this
chorizo like that's what they're in
restaurants
yeah they will call this chorizo uh and
it should
it's a joke i mean it's literally hot
dog i mean it's just a saucy jay
it's just it's just a it's a sad
frankfurt that's what it is
you can pel you can power clothes though
with extreme uncles yeah they don't they
need to try the bacon yeah [ __ ] yeah
i'll give you guys the pizza i'll give
you guys pickle plums because we have
three
okay so this is actually something new
they you know i'm sure the viewers
watching they've tasted bacon before
they've tasted sausages they've tasted
hot dogs yeah what they haven't tasted
is pickled plums so japan is like kind
of known for its people
um it's cool but basically there's two
types of the membership there's the
really really sour types of immediate
yeah that's the only one i've had this
is the sweet um
this is with this one too yes this is
these are all the
sour ones no these are the sweet ones
these are all sweet oh okay yeah
i'll try it so so slightly salted sweet
um shit's dripping everywhere
yeah okay let me let me taste this i
know you guys haven't tried this why
does it look like a deflated scrotum
because it's been because it's been
dried basically what do you think
i'm not a fan i'm starting on a fan bite
yeah there's a there's a seed inside
yeah watch out for the seed oh that's so
sour
this is the sweet one this is the sweet
one okay this is sweet yeah yeah yeah
and what universe is this sweet
yeah this is the sweet one so if you
have the sour one it's literally
like what's the what's the most sour
thing you can normally get
in like south africa it's way it's way
more south you know that one video we
did with joe's channel we had
yeah the powdered sour just like a bite
of that yeah that's basically that's
basically pickled
yeah it's like there's i bought this
thing for my channel which is pure
extract and it's considered one of the
most sour things in the world that's
[ __ ] awful
yeah it's basically you start you start
salivating immediately
it's one of the most sour things you can
just naturally get
it's really good okay
my grandma used to hand make these okay
that's why i have like i do think there
is a lot of at play of like i am not
used to these foods
and although i'm more than happy to try
every single item um
it doesn't mean i have to like every
single item yeah of course what i don't
understand understand about pickled
plums
is that why do you like eating something
that sour
like it's so sour it's more sour than
any kind of sweet
or any kind of i don't know like i used
to like because again like my grandma
used to like hand make
the umeboshi and would just sand it in
tupperware right
and it's like it is the most sour [ __ ]
if i had a japanese
grandma that made it for me i'm sure i'd
love the [ __ ] yeah right i would just
come home
after school and just get the tub wear
and just [ __ ] eat it
that's got love in it yeah this dad
didn't have love
that had factories and suffering that
tastes like [ __ ] my grandmother
was your digital mouth just like this
yeah oh yeah yeah
all the time but i [ __ ] loved it
because that's me off the one bite of
eating um yeah i don't know i love it
yeah another
items that you can get that uh you know
you won't really find elsewhere in the
world
probably is a lot of dried fish items
that are like snackable oh yeah yeah
yeah so gant has some
i have some squid and seaweed tempura
chips so tempura is a kind of
light batter that's a light batter yeah
i have
salmon skin chips which they they really
didn't go with the good names i kind of
[ __ ] with these
i like these yeah i also really [ __ ]
love all of the squid stuff
yeah fried squid uh what's the other one
like the dried squid dried squid as well
i like
they have like a certain type of frying
technique for some of the squids that
are really good
yeah it looks [ __ ] vile when you pull
this out of the package or like octopus
it looks so gross
but it's pretty good uh so should we
bust some of these open
let's try them out joey you want to have
a
oh actually you know what wow they look
like they look like crisps
yeah yeah yeah so these are designed to
basically look like fish crisps
right that's crazy that's kind of epic
like that's kind of epic that's an epic
game
so i'll hold on up right so look at that
that could be like a square
do you have squares in australia uh
there are british british christians no
i don't think they look
exactly like this don't they yeah wow
but they also
they i mean they smell like you they you
just smell it's a very smish
it's a very fishy smell that they smell
like obviously because it's
good i like that with a beer with a bit
oh what the beer
that's great i love that i feel like i
just worked a hard day fishing
in in the middle of nowhere you know
what i mean like
takes me back honestly these these taste
so good with beers
i i just kind of want to eat i'll give
you no give me one okay let's try try
one of these trying to
try one of these i think i've tried
these these have a bit more bite to them
oh
they're like cool yeah it's good they
got some texture to them don't they
yeah that's like the unhealthier version
of this i saw
yeah because it's basically this is
basically that with a bit more batter
so you've got a bit more i think i might
prefer these ones those are nice those
have a really nice crop these have a
nice crunch i'm having another one man
let me bring out a snack that another
snack that i'm sure you guys have
probably never seen or heard of before
okay i'm glad that uh i'm glad that i
actually bought them
what is that ah i did buy these one time
yeah i thought they were chocolate
yeah they weren't chocolate most people
don't look at this they go oh look it's
actual pieces of turd i thought it was
chocolate i was so hyped to dig in
what is it basically it is black sugar
particles but when you black sugar
particles actually like
celery on this it's like fried black
sugar right i'm pretty sure that sounds
like a physics type but when you pull it
out it
straight up just looks like a turd okay
i i don't know what this is that's a
very fancy name for a touch like yeah
that is a turtle brian griffin's poop
there you go what is this you know what
that looks
you know what this looks like this looks
like a turd that like a pomeranian would
do like a small dog
cheers
you know what that ain't bad yeah right
it just tastes like sugar with air
it just tastes like a crisp sugar yeah
it's basically just deep fried sugar
i honestly don't really like that really
that wasn't [ __ ] it's it's a black
sugar is kind of a hit or a mess with a
lot of people
i mean i mean like okay so the thing is
i couldn't eat a whole packet of these
yeah i i chomp on one of these i'm like
that was nice am i
am i getting a craving to do to go for
one more nope
one's enough for me so wait what what is
this in japanese again
this is called
is like the name of the actual snack how
unhealthy is it to just eat the entire
thing
what's the calories on that one calories
uh
698. well how many grams for the whole
bag 130 [ __ ] how
many times how much sugar is in that
[ __ ] i mean you're just eating pure
sugar yeah no
37 grams wait that's way less than i
expected no
i mean it just feels like you're eating
fried sugar there's actually more carbs
in this there's 81 grams of carbs
holy [ __ ] okay
seven grams of uh of protein in this
stuff oh
well great after a workout perfect for
after a workout
where's the protein coming from what the
[ __ ] is the protein coming from no idea
we're literally making protein out thin
air here
japan be doing that did they just put
like a bit of a little bit of protein
powder in it just
pretty much just like balance it out
we're gonna make this healthy somehow
exactly shall we bag full of things now
these are more like i guess sweets or
kind of
all right shall we just shall we just
dump the rest on the table and see what
we got
all right look at look at all that holy
all right should i just start with the
stuff that looks interesting okay first
of all
one of my favorite japanese snacks it's
got to be top it's top tier for me this
estie
what's your senbei senbei in general
though oh yeah in general it's not mochi
but
senbei in general there's a senbei store
not too far from mars yeah i go there
like every week to get my weekly yeah
it's so good oh [ __ ]
senbei is so good if you don't know it's
like a rice cracker but
it's basically like it doesn't feel too
heavy and you can have like one or two
and you feel like really satisfied it's
not too bad for you either yeah i mean
it's just like it feels like it feels
like a crisp but just
lighter and for some reason it's more
filling than a single crisp
oh yeah an entire packet of senbei is
like this yeah oh my god whoa this just
has a funky texture to it
okay is it soft yeah it's like a soft
cookie a soft baked sembe
oh okay is it chewy it looks chewy oh my
god what is that
okay oh this is yeah so mochi senbei is
kind of in the same
so there's different types there's hard
senbei and then there's soft so
there's hard senbei and then this rock
[ __ ] solid ship
there are some senbei where i've had
there was one the there was like it was
like yuzu pepper or something and i was
like oh that sounds amazing
so i order it right and i [ __ ] like
break my teeth i swear biting on this
[ __ ]
what is it like a jawbreaker honestly
there's like there's the perfect
hardness which is just cracks
immediately
it's like a rice cooker right that's
what you want and then some of them it
just feels like you're biting into a
stomach that's really what it is
like if this if this was a cookie i
would think this is the perfect
kind of there's yeah there's actually
one more level
above this called which literally means
wet samba
and it's like actually like wet but they
but they make it for old people who
can't like
break it down that's wholesome okay
let's give it a shot okay
what the [ __ ] whoa that's weird
yeah so mochi rice is actually different
from regular rice mochi rice is a lot
softer and a lot more like squishier
so you get something like this yeah it's
a little it's a little whack ain't it
oh that's so bizarre yeah i don't like
it
okay so two you know what it is it's
it's moist
to explain what to explain laughing
what's funny marlene
to to explain what i just experienced so
as we said this this has the perfect
texture
for like a good cookie and like my
my experience has told me that this is
good i'm going to bite into this and
it's going to taste sweet
and what i tasted was a salted cracker
with a moist cookie texture
that isn't bad though i i'd eat it like
i wouldn't i wouldn't search for it but
i'd eat it
that that was that texture and taste
just doesn't belong together i don't
know some something about that whatever
you've kind of been conditioned right
yeah maybe it's not because i i i
i taste it and it tastes good and i feel
the texture and the texture feels good
but together it just does not synergize
at all
it's like anti-umami man it's like a
plus and a minus
kabuki yoyo these ones i i buy these i
like these
but when you have like four or five you
start to feel sick oh yeah
so like uh what's the what's the word to
describe everything
these are really good yeah so there
it's like how would you describe the
texture it's
cavernous it's like a it's like the
thing from fantastic forwards
i don't know what it is that's like
amazing for like one or two bites but
really like sickly after like three you
know what i mean
i i don't know man i could i could just
maybe maybe it's just me it's probably
just yeah yeah yeah it's not bad though
i mean
these are my favorite types of sandbags
i think so this tastes exactly the same
as what we just had but this is the
texture i imagine that tastes having
it's
it's just like it's a nice salty cracker
just with a bit more air
in between or like it's it's it's fatter
than the cracker but it's lighter than
the cracker yeah it's
it's kind of like eating like cotton
foam
just like flavored right so what are we
having from yours okay so i've never
actually seen this before
but i know this brand baby start army uh
so basically
it's like yeah it is so basically baby
style ramen is like the kind of
really uh what's the word it's like the
dried out ramen
oh is it the instant ramen it's like the
instant ramen looking things but it's in
a snack form
and i guess this is like the mozzarella
flavor right right which i've never seen
that [ __ ]
let me just
oh my god that looks next level i i need
to try this here you go you know
i hate this is my first concern but this
just cannot be even remotely healthy
right of course it's not healthy it's
literally fried in some ramen noodles
it's fine i kind of like it okay
i don't know if you did the same thing
but as a child
sometimes you would sometimes i would
take instant ramen like harden instant
ramen
and just kind of like smash it up into
little pieces put
like put like the seasoning on it and
just eat it like it was like yeah we had
a brand of that it's called mammy
noodles like that would actually sell
packets of that [ __ ]
this is the best are you in prison what
do you want to do because it tastes
[ __ ] great
[ __ ] off you know mammy noodles right i
did the same thing
yeah right yeah have you have you never
had like the ramen
seasoning or like the instagram
seasoning it tastes [ __ ] bomb
it's like it's like putting the
seasoning like msg yeah it's like pure
empty
yeah like it's as as a kid i was told to
never do that because it's unhealthy as
[ __ ] but
it's this but i guess someone someone
grew up
this literally tastes like childhood
yeah it tastes like every asian
childhood it's got a little spice to it
too which is nice
okay okay it's so good on salad salad
you mean croutons they're not crucial
yeah they're not crude
they do look like cream they do kind of
look like a japanese crouton
what is this uh watashi no what is that
karasi what is that yeah that's mustard
what is this i don't actually know i
could open it yeah let's crack it it's
from lawson's
i don't know what it is our intern just
bought it
i'll just that just looks like a potato
it's just shipped i guess
the [ __ ] oh my god that was a kick to it
there we go wow oh my god that is a key
okay i'm not a fan oh yeah you don't
like condoms
this is like condiments in this stone it
tastes like mayo and mustard in a
like a crisp that's so weird i actually
kind of [ __ ] with it it's [ __ ]
horrible
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you're
like condiments
condiments are meant to be you know i
meant to enhance food
they're not meant to be the food i
literally just ate i literally just ate
hardened mustard and mayo
i actually kind of like that yeah it's
actually kind of good hey
it has a really strong like mustard kick
to it so i'll pick another one because i
have too many
yeah what looks interesting that's
we literally have these in the uk yeah
yeah that's this one what are those
what's this uh
like the biscuits oh yeah the creams the
custard creams custard cream biscuits
yeah i look like
um this is cognac chip seaweed and salt
konyaku oh kanyaku yeah
low in calories natural lawsons okay
okay should we give it a shot oh yeah
yeah
konyaku does have zero calories so well
well wow gamers let's give it a shot
go on go ahead thank you very much go
ahead
that tastes like air with an off with
like a hint of seaweed i'll try these
the moment like moisture hits it it just
dissolves and disappears that was
literally like eating nothing
you know what it was it was rice crispy
ever been scaled up in size but not with
like the added ingredients
needed to scale it up it's literally
just take going to photoshop
have you seen that video on the internet
where someone manages to like deep fry
water yes someone managed to deep fry
water right like a like
like a packet of water that's what i
imagine that tastes like how would you
do that why would i do that
all right i've got here castella don't
know
what kind of celery is all that's like a
specific type of japanese because
normally it's
uh in like a block it's like a block
yeah which country is castella from
look it up what is castella do you want
to explain well we'll find out
okay custard is like a cake of kinds
right it's like a pastry okay it looks
like a pastry it's uh it's really
[ __ ] good
oh look is it really okay so it's made
in japan it looks like a little pastry
it's good it's like a cream puff okay
let me let me um
that's good that is [ __ ] good
one thing i've noticed about the pastry
here that i love
everything is fluffy as [ __ ] yeah i love
you give me another one of those
those are [ __ ] clean you just want a
castella like from the shortcake
to the bread to the uh
to the whipped cream to the [ __ ]
castella everything is so fluffy
soft and fluffy soft and fluffy i saw a
bit just [ __ ]
which is why it's so easy to eat sweets
here because they find a different way
to market different kind of sweets and
they all taste [ __ ] amazing
you can't you really can't go what's
wrong with sweets well i'm going to try
something from the family mart
collection
it's using proper italian caramel sauce
popcorn isn't caramel just sugar it's
literally just fried chicken
but like i won't lie one thing that i've
been as i've said in the past before
with the movie theaters
i've been very impressed with popcorn
japan they have really taken popcorn
i've i'm not a huge fan of popcorn but
let me try
honestly japanese popcorn if you come
here it's [ __ ] good yeah you think
popcorn is like an american staple like
it's good [ __ ]
actually that's not too sweet that is
just popcorn i don't know
i don't i don't really go to a movie
theater in japan
make sure you get popcorn get the half
and half you want me to disappoint
the thing about popcorn popcorn is me is
that i'm never the one to buy popcorn
but i'll always take it if someone's
gone always like i never got
like i never got out of my way to be
like okay i am craving popcorn now i
need popcorn i'm always the guy who's
just like okay there's popcorn
i mean i'm going to take some if it's
there but i'm never going to go
i'll never order my own popcorn at a
theater no if someone has popcorn i'm
taking it
exactly right if i'm offered i'm not
going to say no just read what this is
called
this is the most unappetizing name i've
ever heard in my life okay
sugar rusk is the english name
and it's actually in japanese says
are you sure they didn't like just try
to spill out sugar rush i'm just
kind of [ __ ] i'm having a sugar
where's the fortnite chug chug
wow look at that what is it let me take
one
what is okay i i look at this mini
baguette
i look at this and i'm like this should
not taste sweet if i bite into this and
and it tastes this is like those like
party baguettes where you put like a
little bit of like
uh like salmon on top yeah
like at a fancy house party
why oh but it's really sweet why
it's literally sugar on a baguette it's
sugar on a baguette no
no no [ __ ] up i'm not going to [ __ ]
get
the [ __ ] out of here that is like going
against like [ __ ] everything the
france fought
like france fought for they did not have
the french revolution so this could
happen yeah exactly
oh god to help us out oh god lawson's
has a collaboration with
how do you pronounce this good either
good either good good is it god of all
god either i think it's gotta be right
no one knows it's god over so they have
like their own collection of like
chocolates
is that curry bread it's curry bread oh
no oh no
this is chocolate bread this is beef
curry bread
in a chocolate bun yo crack that open
let's give it a shot let's give it a
shot
okay okay this is this is going to be a
trash case first here but what because i
have
literally never got your shirt
that looks like a donut it's like it
looks like curry bread but
with it's if it's like made out of
chocolate okay so open up a napkin and
rip that [ __ ] over so to explain what
curry bread is normally like
it's literally you take japanese curry
and then you deep fry it in a katsu
right
and uh cuts your bread and then it's
it's kind of it's kind of like a jelly
filled doughnut
except imagine the filling was curry
yeah that's correct and it's [ __ ]
good curry normal curry bread is [ __ ]
amazing this is not normal
this is an abomination
i'm excited to i'm actually excited i
want to know what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah
like how is the synergy of chocolate and
coconut
if i like this what is that okay i would
say for um experience points
one of the worst combinations i've had
was when i went to the wisconsin state
fair
in the usa and they were and they were
selling
uh chocolate bacon they would literally
take bacon
and dip it in chocolate i'm going i'm
about to find out if
there is a worse combination right now
than chocolate bacon
i don't know chocolate bacon sounds
[ __ ] horrible okay well chocolate
curry bread
that's also sounds horrible all right oh
okay look at that okay so
it looks like it literally looks like a
curry in between chocolate bread
that smells like just a contradiction
you know let's give it a bite let's
fight into it boys
oh that's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up
that ain't right no
i don't like that um do you like that
joey
i kind of like it no wait
no that's awful oh that's all that is so
awful oh my god oh my god
i don't know if i'm just [ __ ] up but
that just tastes like curry bread to me
no it tastes what are you talking about
i i legitimately can't taste the
chocolate
i can't taste the chocolate all i get is
like a weird bitter aftertone
it's it's even worse than chocolate
bread because it's not even sweet
it's the you can taste the cocoa in the
chocolate
and then you bite into it and then you
get a mouthful of curry
it's the worst it's an aftertaste that
you sh
this is like legitimately can't taste
the chocolate yeah i taste the do you
taste the cocoa though right
no i bet with this one it's going to be
rich this is the chocolate bread
and it's their collaboration with godivo
oh god that get that away from me i
literally feel to me that just tastes
like a curry bread sorry i
i liked it
now that
yeah yeah that was heavy that's that's
how chocolate look should look like
chocolate breads yes
dude i get like a nosebleed after eating
one piece of good i have a chocolate let
alone this whole [ __ ] bread
the chocolate bread which actually looks
pretty [ __ ] good oh yeah that was
good
that's because they're not being
adventurous with [ __ ] curry bread
yeah
if there's one thing you shouldn't put
in chocolate bread it's curry it's a
nice cross section
we've got some oh that is very strong
our chocolate paste on chocolate bread
smells like heaven a whiff sorry
oh that's
[ __ ] that's really good honestly a
little disappointed
really okay no no you don't like that i
really like it the bread
the chocolate tastes very artificial the
chocolate tastes good i don't like the
bread
that tastes not as good as like it it's
chewy bread as well it's not the fluffy
bread
chewy bread doesn't taste good with the
chocolate that they put in there
i'll [ __ ] with it joey you [ __ ] with any
anything joey
i do like is that [ __ ] weird i [ __ ]
with that yeah
is it like what is it is this is this
seasoned vomit i mean i'm gonna try it
oh okay
i mean i i'd [ __ ] [ __ ] with that i'm
the kind of guy who's like i don't want
to
offend anyone so if i went to another
country and they're like oh this is what
we eat and i just vomit with seasoning
i'd be like
well i mean i you know i don't want to
offend anyone so i'll give it a shot
yeah
i mean i'll be like it's great yeah you
don't have to like it
at all yeah just trying it just trying
it i think is like more of an
appreciation to the culture
honestly anything else what was
presented here was a massive
disappointment
from the usual kind of it looks like sex
yeah this looks like set like it tastes
like it should be like [ __ ] amazing
and how many calories is this bad boy
254 calories uh 31 grams of
sugar carbohydrates and 29 grams of
sugar so damn
the black sugar poop pieces were more
less healthier than that
yeah i know and i've got here some
almond cookies
yo okay i [ __ ] with that but in japanese
it's called almond balls
wait why do they look like that what i
don't know what they don't look like
they look like these they look like bon
bons yeah they look like [ __ ] bonbons
aren't they okay that's
uh i do [ __ ] with anything that has
almonds
i'm just kidding almonds are usually my
favorite type of nut oh that's kind of
nice yeah
almond is a good nut almond is like top
tier one of the top
if we were gonna like tear the nuts
almonds up
all right let's give it a shot boys whoa
that was weird it's got it's covered in
powder sugar
okay so i thought i don't know why i
thought it was gonna be soft on the
inside it wasn't
it's just it's just shortbread you know
what this tastes like it tastes like
something you'd buy in hawaii
you know what i mean it's like very like
why hawaii it tastes like someone
you go to like a food festival and
they're like here's our new weird thing
we mash up almonds put them in a bowl
and put sugar on them it's like i mean
yeah sure i don't know it tastes very
like kind of like tropical
it's good it's good but like why just
eat it
it just tastes like shortbread with a
bit of almond that's true yeah
that's spa actually yeah it's it's
shortbread with almond and some frosting
on the side
i think that's literally just trying to
i mean that's literally all it is that
definitely just describes what it was
i just described it as a whole
that's that's okay i mean that's you
know it's okay i'm not gonna go and buy
that okay
now we are getting to the point where it
you might recognize some of these brands
but uh so i've got here some kitkat
sweet potatoes what is that sweet potato
right that's
uh that's benimo which is uh like red
potato i
i think it's called taro in uh in
english
i i don't know you have no you always
it's just sweet potatoes
okay so this is sweet potatoes whenever
you see this paste or this color it's
always sweet potato i've learned in
japan yeah
they love it they put it on everything
yeah honestly sweet potato kind of slaps
but whoa uh okay oh
it's hello it's a bowl of kitkats let's
it's like a kit cat ball we'll fight
that in half we have a cross section
going on
okay it's like wafer yeah it's good yeah
i would eat that and you can't go wrong
with the kitkat i find no
i feel like this is just a kitkat it is
i mean it's literally just they took a
kitkat and they went
obviously i would say that tastes better
than a kitkat i prefer that over a
regular kitkat yeah i i would say
you don't oh is that is that one or one
bag
uh one bag i was gonna say it was one
244 calories for one ball i was like oh
my god i'm gonna go to the toilet
all three of us would have had a heart
attack oh my god i was getting scared i
was like why does it taste so good
all right i got uh i've never seen these
before
yeah pretz this is smoked uh potato
butter flavor so pretz is just like
cooked potato pudding
smoked potatoes are just like basically
f uh
flavor savory potatoes i'm losing words
right now
i prefer pretz over pocky personally
they have uh i mean they're savory if
you go to the supermarket you'll see
that flavor and you always see the pizza
flavor
oh yeah yeah so they have pizza flavored
sticks which i
feel like why we should eat a [ __ ]
pizza just eat a pizza pizza
please pizza shouldn't be a flavor
because there's different flavors of
pizza so what is pizza flavor
i quite like that i like that i hate
that i like that you can never go wrong
with pretz honestly yeah
if you're looking for a savory snack
pretz is the way to go oh that
aftertaste is gross
i'm getting a really bad aftertaste you
can you can taste like what's this
what's this flavor again
smoky potato butter i can taste the
smokiness of it i can taste the butter
as well
oh jesus that's awful okay another one
from natural lawson so there are two
types of lawsons
i'm getting very full gentlemen we're
nearly done we're nearly done
there was the natural lawsons which is
has tends to have more healthy options
healthy snacks
healthy uh meals it's actually pretty
good it's a pretty pretty cool marketing
strategy
um and so they have their own brand of
stuff and this is the cranberry cookies
with
gaba cranberry cookie gaba gaba as it
says isn't gaba like the stuff they put
in energy drinks
oh yeah it is isn't it yeah
cookie that's what it says in japanese
very good japanese hunger jose
i was looking for gaba and i was like
where's gaba it's literally at the top
it says gabba gabba you're gonna point
out the camera
they literally spoke gabba in english
yeah it's like a bucket
it's called cameron she gave up on their
own language
it's enriched chocolate enriched
chocolate that's what gaba is
amino amino beatrice acid so this is
exactly what
this is supposed to be healthy so uh
what is it like
yeah so the stuff in natural laws and is
way more healthy so it should be
healthier
so one of these is is that one
one bag 65 calories is that right 7.5
grams
oh that might be i'll just give it a
shot anyway you can tell me joey i'll
hand it to you okay
there you go okay okay that's uh
this whoa this looks like a diet this
looks like a diet
this is a belvita yeah this looks like a
diet snack it looks like a diet bar
how many calories a bag or like what is
it uh so it's per
meal meal yeah which is 17
and a half grams oh this is 35 grams so
okay so
two so there's a hundred hundred so half
a half a bag is 65 kilo
calories that's not bad yeah first for
like what looks to be like a very heavy
snack yeah
so let's have a taste that's literally
like a belvita it is a belvita what's a
belleville it's like the the diet like
cookies or diet biscuits with like
it's all you have them in every country
no this tastes like something like my
grandma would have had
you know like something something like
it's like grandma can i have some snacks
and she's like here you go
actually i quite like it i like that
tastes nice i actually if i had a
natural lawson closer to me i'd probably
get that yeah
that's actually fun cranberry favorite
stuff is actually really good yeah i'm
taking that home with me
[Music]
a little ziploc bag fantastic should we
talk about some of the stuff
at the front okay yeah i want to talk
about this
i really like these these are the ramune
flavored
um what is candy candy i have
an ancient video on my channel from like
six years ago where
i bought like a box of those candy right
and i said to myself
would i be able
i emptied like 30 of these into a bowl
and i crushed them into a powder and
then i mixed it with the carbonated
water
to see if it would go back into a ramen
spoilers it doesn't go back into ramen
um i've only ever had the drink a few
times it's quite nice but i mean
it's basically what how do you how would
you describe ramen it's basically like a
japanese uh lemonade right yeah japanese
wow yeah i love these is this this you
love this
i do i grew up with this [ __ ] yeah okay
i was like eating a kid
i i i eat this and i'm like i taste a
childhood i never had
no wonder you look like 10 gone because
you're [ __ ] eating kids [ __ ] all the
time
probably what were you drinking like
breast milk still all the time like
what's going on
like i would secretly i would eat this
what connor has the right there
chocolate babies i love these
these are great these are like these are
terrible though because like
you think you're not eating a lot of
chocolate because it's so [ __ ]
dense i i look at this and i thought it
was going to be a tic tac
that's that right the first time i just
tried it i thought it was a picture
it looks like a tic tac and you bite
into it and it's just
it's just like chocolate it's pure
chocolate chocolate as well though
it's the most inoffensive chocolate that
it's like
it's the good chocolate you would eat as
a kid
yeah literally just tic tac chocolate
version yeah pretty much
it makes chocolate way too easy to eat
because because you just
the supermarkets have the big versions
yeah and if i get them it's almost
impossible
it's like it's like eating sprinklings
and oh that's that's my childhood right
there like this big as well
tiny that's my childhood very nice milk
chocolate
that's good the other thing though that
is my childhood
is these things um i bought i hate these
these suck
have you tried these no oh yeah you can
try it okay
so these they're literally called umaibo
which means tasty stick
that's literally what it's called okay
and it's basically
oh god how do you even explain it so
basically there's like these have been
around since like the [ __ ] 20s like
these are ancient
and they're 10 yen each all right
[ __ ] nothing but feel how light that
is these are the spacers
these are the space raiders of japan i
think this this is because this is
packaged air
yeah if you throw this high enough into
the air it'll just go off this has
no weight at all what's the actual
weight written on the package
uh oh dozens
six grams six grams
but i guarantee i'm pretty sure most of
the grams is the packaging
is this the [ __ ] packaging i'm
literally holding air here so i'm i have
the corn portage flavored
it's like cornstarch dude this this just
looks like monster this just looks like
monsters
i've got the cheese one you should try
it
what is this flavor those are the mint i
call flavor the skoda
this is just monsters crisps yeah isn't
it
crisps if they were made by space
raiders do you have space traders in
australia i've heard of those yeah
all right let's try this there's a big
watcher
it takes away all the moisture in your
mouth yeah it's a monster's crisp it's
just a what's it yeah it's a big what's
it man this is
usually just a watson honestly i mean i
could i can understand why you that was
your childhood americans this is a
cheeto
i mean honestly dude like imagine like
you're like a five-year-old right yeah
you're giving like a hundred yen of like
just you know pocket money from your
grandmas of course you're buying 10
years
i'm buying 10 of these like these these
[ __ ] are going to fill me up
for until dinner
honestly i mean who who doesn't love
[ __ ] whatsits or monsters christmas
or whatever
just just cheese sticks oh cheek
yeah i can guarantee though that these
are probably not the best tasting cheese
well i also grew up with these but
uh after about age eight i stopped
eating them because i had proper cheese
in australia
when you have real cheese you can't eat
this but if you're american
i'm not funny this is not just cheese
this is cheese with kama boko which is
fish cake
you should have said that you should let
him try it just give it a go you want to
try it girl
sure you're on the show there's you
can't say no i'm actually really look at
that
what the [ __ ] is this what the [ __ ]
how the hell do i
eat these joey i'm gonna be honest this
is probably the least
appetizing looking thing that we've had
on today oh
dude you kind of just rip it open like
that we've had some pretty gross [ __ ]
but this looks vile
this actually looks disgusting this
looks like on the same level with squish
what's the ratio of cheese to like
fish you don't want to smell them
how do i open this this immediately just
like grab the top and just put
that like a banana
[Music]
these boys are struggling here here i'll
open them up for you there you go okay
let me let me let me get the [ __ ] okay
yeah there you go just get a knife
there we go oh okay hell yo
fort knox should be this actually taste
this actually smells
close to vomit i think as close to
vomiting it's like a cheesy vomit isn't
it yeah that's
it all right i'm gonna have one because
i haven't i haven't had these
i haven't had one of these since i was
about eight okay
is this going to be cheese flavored
vomit like i imagine it to be
yeah it tastes exactly how i remember it
oh we want to try this japanese snack
for first time honestly
it doesn't taste as bad as i thought it
would it oh
it tastes like you're eating plastic
yeah
it tastes like you're eating plastic and
then you get the fish aftertaste
the fish where is the cheese in there i
don't taste anything that was not
cheese that was plastic you can't you
can't
that's a plastic fish sausage that's
fish
that's fish flavored plastic i have a
melty kiss
as they're called as they say in all the
commercials
yeah um and uh i don't particularly like
these you know
ah it's just uh mochi right what have
you been watching
yeah it's like mochi with like chocolate
on it yeah well
let's give it a shot you're not a fan of
mochi
ah mochi's hair mystery of course
because japan they're individually
packaged yeah
love the packaging you say you will it's
[ __ ] pretty like the
box makes you want the thing the thing
about melty kiss is one of those
uh brands in japan that is always
seasonal they always have a seasonal
flavor of melty kiss you
you can tell what time period you are in
when you go to a supermarket or a
company and you see what melody kisses
around and as the name suggests uh they
melt pretty [ __ ] fast
yeah so i i really like it it's
i like him it is just basically mochi we
have chocolate
and it's just basically actually you
know what that's really good yeah
i don't know what melty kiss you had i
think i had an awful like tasting one
this is just chocolate this is [ __ ]
good this is chocolate chips this is
really rich chocolate it's just
chocolate truffle right
there's no mochi in this is that yeah
does it think so
there might be a mochi variant oh i
thought it was mochi so
i tasted that i didn't taste any more
like
and thank god they're all individually
wrapped so we can enjoy those later yeah
um i also have this is my channel that's
the mod
what is this oh my god i can't read
[ __ ] the phone come on you're nihongo
josu you can do it
you're just trying to try to figure it
out bro it's the fancy fonts [ __ ] me up
in japanese so
that's cute so it's separated into cute
little packages oh cute
so that's like perfect for dates yeah
yeah man you and your gf
rocking up okay how do you feel about
mochi um mid-tier
it depends it depends on the time like
mochi ice cream and like regular mochi
and like sweet small cheese is like
completely different in my opinion so
what is what is mochi again
mochi is just rice it's rice pudding
yeah so mochi is just rice
so basically they grab uh mochi rice
which is a specific type of rice
and they just [ __ ] mash it with a
hammer until it turns into
mochi that's good it's very chewy it's
just good shape
yeah that's clean
how i always feel about mochi is that
it's just very inoffensive
i would never not eat mochi but i would
never go out my way to get it but you
know like a lot of
old people die from choking on mochi i
can see why
yeah so when you eat mochi make sure
you're like yeah make sure you like
properly chew this [ __ ] otherwise it
will get stuck in your throat
i'm sorry i was laughing because i saw
one of gaunt's item i keep forgetting
it's called this it's called the
chocolate pound cake
for some reason that feels so that is
such a sexual energy
i never thought about that i was like
yeah pound cake of course
but when you say it in english it's
really weird that's the chocolate pound
pound you want to give you want to get
some chocolate pound cake that feels
yeah see that that has like that
i've never had a food item that has raw
sexual energy but that has it i mean
y'all want chocolate pound cake what
that what that pound cake dude
honestly i mean it's just cake i don't i
don't use a fat block of chocolate yeah
i'll [ __ ] with you yeah that's good
i i know what this tastes like yeah i
don't just taste it you're gone when god
has run out of energy
he'll run into the 7-eleven or like
family mart just buy one of these
yeah i don't know how you do that so
sometimes i just need a sugar rush
uh i don't i don't know it's just a
brownie yeah it literally just tastes
like a brownie
yeah i mean i mean like it's just a
brownie you don't i don't need to do
this but it's
way more sexually sounding than a
broccoli a pound cake
pound cake does sound better than
brownie yeah
that's nice right yeah that's not bad
that's sexy
all right i think we are almost done
what do you have
i've got these like chocolates choco pie
oh god no yeah that just looks like a
panda chocolate
yeah but like not as good
france is crying right now i don't
really [ __ ] with these to be honest
yeah um i'm gonna be honest i don't need
to try that yeah
yeah let's not open let's let's let's
open the stuff that is like only
what is like that the [ __ ] is that kid
this is a
melon kitkat you're kidding me wow
because they don't have a kitkat they
have
yeah like uh like that's a hokkaido
melon cake cat so that's the good melon
see the thing about like hokkaido melons
is that it is expensive as [ __ ] yeah
because apparently it's super amazing
let's
uh poke melons for preference like
one like maybe about that big but a
regular thing will cost you like two
three hundred dollars
it's like it's like the top class of
melon
oh this is the bowl variety that we
tried yeah is this
just gonna taste like kitkat again whoa
i [ __ ] with that
i love melon flavored [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that's good yeah
that is really good oh my god
that might be one of the best ones of
china hey give me some of that
that's probably the best kitkat i've
ever had in my life that is
that is such a clean flavor to it like
that straight up tastes like you're
eating a melon yeah
wow that's crazy it's it's like the
crunchiness of a biscuit and a kitkat
but with the clean taste of them of a
fruit wow i can't
that's really good wow you know how you
buy
a melon and it's god damn you know how
you bite into a melon and it just like
it feels like clean because it feels
like you're eating like a really watery
fruit yeah yeah for some reason that was
a completely dry
snack that we just had but it felt
watery
we don't need to try that it's called
sugar butter sand tree the [ __ ] is that
it just looks like a custard it's a 7-11
brand too yeah
[ __ ] that i have um
wasabi sticks it looks like is that
cheese and what's happening
oh that's jagariko which is like a brand
of like uh savory steaks
i guess this is like wasabi show you
flavor right dude do you like wasabi
snacks no i do not get them i like the
wasabi like beans
the wasabi seed like flavored things i
forgot what they were called but like
i know we talked about peanut butter
yeah there's there's like there's like
beans that are covered in wasabi yeah i
[ __ ] with those
i mean let me smell this for me wasabi
just doesn't feel like something that
should be snacked on
that's basic as [ __ ] did you chase
anything i don't say something i taste
the wasabi yeah
i barely oh a little bit tiny bit oh
yeah there it is because when we eat
something wasabi flavor we're
used to the whole like kickback right
but this is just like literally just a
hint of wasabi flavor honestly it's not
too overpowering i like that
[ __ ] yes i literally were just [ __ ]
on wasabi
snacks literally five minutes ago and
that's because the wasabi normally what
happens with wasabi snacks is that it
overpowers whatever
you think like i can probably taste the
soy sauce on that as well yeah and like
i i
i i ate that and i was like i can't even
taste the wasabi but then
you get that aftertaste you literally
just did like the kombucha girl like
you're like no wasabi actually these are
pretty good yeah because you know you
know when you have bad sushi
and then you you kind of like try to
overpower it with wasabi just to get rid
of the taste like that
what who does that do you do that
sometimes sometimes really
but like i don't find myself in a bad
sushi restaurant i know a good one no no
no no no joey
was louis he didn't go into a bed again
[ __ ]
you go to some sushi restaurants
especially with friends from abroad and
you see them
like put a little bit of soy sauce and
then [ __ ] wasabi yeah and then it's
it's like 90 wasabi
10 soy sauce and they just basically
just dipped the entire season
[ __ ] drown it in and i don't know how
they can taste the fish that's the
incorrect way
to eat sushi yeah finally okay and i
feel like this is the perfect kind of
balance
of like how how a good sushi should
taste like actually i really like those
damn what's the gigger video coming on
about these you went on a [ __ ]
but final thing we have is matcha
classic
we could have had about a bazillion
match items we wanted to i think
honestly i think matcha is my favorite
kind of
weren't you the guy like sit like seven
months ago thought match was overrated
i don't think so no i don't think that
was gone or someone else goes on
i think that's like that shows overhyped
i feel like i feel that's like okay
so you're you are the guy who think
matches i think matcha is awesome i feel
that's the two dichotomies with matcha
though it's either you think it's
[ __ ] amazing with everything or you
think it's overrated
i think i think it's great i mean in the
last podcast we were we
recorded i had a matcha latte
to me matcha is kind of like sometimes
i'll eat one sometimes like
it's like handing a cigarette over all
right
gentlemen i've had these before these
are great yeah these are great
i mean it's fine much snacks
are great i'd rather a chocolate based
thing honestly have you okay
one one question have you ever had
matcha soft served
yeah because matcha soft serve is
literally the
single-handedly changed my opinion of
matcha because after i had much a soft
serve i'm like
much tastes [ __ ] great oh yeah yeah
oh we have moles sorry
okay we have this thing which is gohan
gohan which is basically this like i
don't even know what the flavor of it is
it's just gohan this your flavor but
basically you put it on
a bed of rice and it basically
it's good on rice that's all it is
bro you're kidding me that's all that
smells like seaweed
it's a seaweed it's a seaweed paste but
you would give this to like kids
i think i inhaled an x amount of salt
just from being near there
well that's the thing because it's so
salty you put that on a better rice and
it mellows it out perfectly
this is uh this is i'm not gonna eat
that i'm not eating now this is this is
jagger
choco and it's just potato chips it
looks like to be
chocolate which is chocolate it looks
like chocolate potato chips looks like
it hasn't been um
you're not [ __ ] i can make
assumptions all day as
the great lord says let's just jump
right into it
oh oh okay okay okay that's uh
uh yeah i think i've tried these before
looking a little anemic
i mean it's literally just a chocolate
potato chip will it be salty though
that's what i'm curious about
yes they are weirdly salty you can't
taste the chocolate there's too much
salt
i'm having a kombucha tea my own right
now
it's like not gonna lie
no that's a little too much salt for me
oh too much
you know what that tastes like it tastes
like you ate
a bag of crisps and then you instantly
downed with like a hot chocolate if i'm
gonna
that's what that tastes like get double
calories of eating crisps and chocolate
i want to enjoy
both right i don't want to like have one
and then just eat calories from no
[ __ ]
i'm going to cleanse my palate with this
what is that one thing you have over
there
what's that polar bear thing you have uh
it's basically
what the [ __ ] is this
i think it's it's just basically melty
kiss this is this give me this
oh it's kind of the same thing let's try
it out it's like a brownie i guess let's
try this it's giving me an existential
crisis don't you keep eating it
oh they're big whoa look at the
packaging it comes in dude that's fancy
oh what is that i don't know let's crack
it open though
aren't you okay no i'm not okay it's not
good god why why are we deciding
if it's good or not because it tastes
good and then it doesn't and then it
does and then it doesn't and then it
i'm so [ __ ] confused it's like it's
yeah again it's like a melty kiss but
huh kind of more fancy looking
just grab one let's pop it out
yeah it's like a mini brownie
whoa oh it's not like a mini brownie
well it's like if snow was chocolate
oh actually it says powder snow
chocolate
there you go the the branding on point
man that's so rich
that instantly melts away holy [ __ ] you
wanna try that hold on
you're still having an extra facial
glasses with that one i think i like
this
really i it took me three bites
afterwards deliberation
i i couldn't i didn't hear whatever you
guys were talking about because i was
true
guys he likes it i was just trying to
figure out if this was a taste that i
like and
it's just doesn't say this it was like
it was like having like an ancient greek
like
philosophy like aristotle moment in his
head while we were eating this
so what what is it that you're talking
about what is this this is powder snow
chocola
it literally just melts away
this man can't make up this much better
anything this honestly has [ __ ] me up
because i'm just like do i like things
now
what do i like anymore what is life oh
god i feel sick
i don't i don't eat chocolate but this
is more chocolate than i've had
so this is i remember how we were
debating if we were going to have dinner
after
filming this episode we are not having
that dinner after filming so
i just enjoyed the atmosphere of having
a dinner together this year
this is not a dinner with the boys you
literally just witnessed three people
have dinner together
two hours yeah for two weeks a literal
combini dinner
what would you say is your favorite i
guess item from each
genre of food so you're starting the hot
foods first yeah so hot foods which one
it
which one brings the cream in the hole
okay hot food i'm i'm still standing
seven
seven if you want to find chicken lawson
fried chicken man seven fried chicken
seven beef bowl seven any hot food
honestly i think i think lawson have
been doing the hot food better man
that'll be gonna be real with you man if
i'm gonna be the mediator i would have
to
just give it to the seven you [ __ ]
for real
yes yes i'd have to just give him a sec
again i don't eat the fried food so i
don't [ __ ] care
all we know is that family my friend
sucks ass i never get the fried food
from the community because i'm just like
if i'm gonna if i'm gonna have fried
food i'm gonna go to a [ __ ]
restaurant yeah if i'm gonna [ __ ] up my
body
i'm gonna do it in a good place yeah you
know what i mean hey good money yeah
i want the best [ __ ] if this is like my
cheat day right yeah
um what about the best like sandwiches
then oh
sandwich probably lawson's have i
converted you into seeing the way of the
tuna sandwich
i mean look the tuna the tuna sandwich
is lawson is definitely better but the
egg sandwich family mods better
if only they could join forces yeah i
would agree if only they could join
forces
like runny egg sandwiches should never
be a thing it's not ronnie
it it does i don't know about it it's a
paste it's mashed up
it's the collab we want to happen
like egg paste shouldn't be a thing it's
not paste it's just it's mashed down
i wanna like i wanna taste the eggs i
want the texture
i don't need it i don't need it i need
it like even i prefer it
even even scrambled egg has a texture
this was like scrambled egg that was put
into a paste
it is it is i like it it's like egg
flavored gluten
to me the egg is like they're both very
strong
but to me the tuna is just so much
better the tuna is hands down better
it's like why would i want it and also
uh like
there's supermarkets that like aren't
any of those that get like the
sandwiches as well and the tuna always
tastes like the family
one for some reason yeah yeah for some
reason i feel the awesome one they
actually took like the canned tuna and
juice yeah it's good [ __ ] yeah good
[ __ ] chicken i feel like the lawsons
one the tuna sandwiches is better
definitely better the egg sandwiches
family mart will definitely better
i don't eat that many sandwiches from
the combinies so i don't really have
too much of a strong opinion what about
what about the uh onigiri the rice balls
lawsons lawsons
yeah hands down lawson's hands down size
of one type
yeah i did not realize though that
because we we saw
two seven on the yuri's i don't know if
one will not will make it to the final
cut but we opened up two
they both looked as depressing as each
other my god
pretty sad the awesome one was clean it
was it was nicely wrapped around that
was an
art piece right yeah yeah and the
fillings were in every single bite like
that's
no matter where i buy i need to get a
bit of filling yeah absolutely
lost lawson's definitely by far the best
on a year thank you guys thank you
appreciate you appreciate it uh what
about
the what else did we cover i guess
snacks like we had like the
like fish snacks meat snacks i mean the
fish snacks and meat snacks i think we
can all agree are all pretty mid
yeah they're all they're all like the
same level they're all oh no i like the
fish crisps
and fish crisps yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think that the the way that lawsons do
the squid as well i was really [ __ ]
yeah yeah we unfortunately didn't get to
try any like dried squid or white fish
or something but
like it's it's something that a lot of
people from
you know america and england that i've
met have because i bring this [ __ ] from
thailand
to england and people like why are you
eating fish food
it kind of it kind of does smell a bit
like food a little bit yeah
it does but it tastes [ __ ] awesome
it's the perfect amount of salty it's
perfect to go with your beer
absolutely uh fish snacks just you can't
like you you don't know the full
enjoyment of fish snacks until you've
had a cold beer with them
yeah you could have a beer with them i
don't know and i must say i'm thoroughly
impressed with the one cop personally
i thought i was gonna [ __ ] you you know
what i finished it i i'm impressed i'm
impressed i thought it was gonna taste
like [ __ ] and it tasted
not great but drinkable but way better
than chris i would
i would i would buy another one of those
what the [ __ ] did did chris just bring
us like
just like the spices yeah yeah the worst
one he could find
he's just like pissed in a bottle he's
like yeah trust me
he's so
i also really like these though i love
it i like them but i think the kitkat
melon was just
above the rest and then obviously all
the breads disappointed me
yeah the breads were kind of made this
though no no no no
no no no it's not let me let me just
choco babies get go get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah and again like you know like
the ramen and stuff like that the
chocolate baby the stuff that i grew up
with this shit's great
oh you're having another existential
crisis right now
[ __ ] i i took a bite and i was just like
this tastes awful and i'm just like no
this tastes good
you gotta [ __ ] try this please try
this
you don't have to okay no i i got it the
initial taste tastes [ __ ] awful
all right and then the aftertaste kicks
in and i'm like this tastes like uh
what does taste the aftertaste gives me
the same kind of taste i
when when you're cooking like a brownie
or something and you have like cooking
chocolate
and you took you're cooking like a
chocolate pudding and then as a kid you
kind of just like
have a bit of the chocolate you know you
see it doesn't
i wasn't listening i was just enjoying
connor looking dead over there
it doesn't taste like that you're
chatting [ __ ] but all in all
i'd have to say you can get like this
you're a woman
you're a winner if you're in japan is
not even all of that this is not even
a corner of what you can get at a
company [ __ ] the best
tasting thing what was the worst tasting
thing oh god okay
because i'm having a hard time deciding
between this
and this oh no honestly the crab cake
the crab cake oh the crab cake was
pretty cool no actually
it's it's this for me this is this has
the worst
aftertaste and crab cake i still have
the aftertaste of this in my mouth right
now
after eating all that [ __ ] was gross
yeah chica i mean
i i grew up i grew up with chico and
there's a reason why i stopped eating it
because it's
it's literally right it literally smells
like vomit yeah it ain't rich
that was probably the worst flavored one
was the worst thing but yeah again
like this is nowhere near the variety
that you can get at a convenience store
right like
there's so many more snacks i mean you
know i haven't even talked about the
fact that you know you can buy
basically [ __ ] anything at a
convenience store pay your utility bills
yeah you can send packages you can send
packages you can yeah
toiletries you can get you know like
lawson's next to me
has now basically just has a whole
section
for like household items like you can
buy like bed sheets
like soap containers yeah yeah yeah yeah
like yeah weird [ __ ] that you're like
why do i need this here it's like a mini
ikea
lawson it's so strange but really cool
but you can buy stuff like you can buy
technical stuff like sd cards
yeah yeah like charges and stuff like
that yeah i bought
i bought underwear from uh i have a pair
of honestly the best pair of socks i've
bought in japan yeah
from lawson they're really [ __ ] i i
have gloves
like the hand gloves that i bought from
family mart and i still wear them to
this yeah right
yeah so super super community so like
definitely when you come to japan
whenever the world opens up
uh yeah let us know what your favorite
is yeah yeah let us know what your
favorite is
yeah yeah it might be neither of ours it
could be it could be mini stop it could
be yamazaki who knows and like chris
broad know that he's
his [ __ ] taste thing that family mock
chicken is the best family mart chicken
is not the best that's the real loser
here
yeah the real loser is the fact that
chris thinks their family might taste
good if you come to japan
please go to family mart chicken i've
family mart get the chicken
and just you know validate our opinion
because please be disappointed [ __ ]
awful yeah also let us know if you
enjoyed this episode which is a very
different format to our usual yeah yeah
i just kind of wanted to try this out to
kind of
you know give you guys something a
little bit different than just us
chatting [ __ ] for two yeah we're just
experimenting which we will get back to
very shortly absolutely but in the
meantime look at all these patrons
wow look at this guy here look at that
guy and that guy
he stopped that chicken this guy doesn't
eat crab cakes
with cheese but yeah if you guys would
like to support us uh make sure to go to
patreon.com
trash test also send us your memes on
twitter the subreddit and listen to us
on spotify maybe not this episode don't
listen to this episode
a bit late if you've got this far yeah
yeah yeah yeah we warned you right at
the beginning but every other episode
you can probably listen to on spotify
apologies to any audio only listeners
who
have attempted to get through this
episode they're just like imagining what
everything looks like it's like
they probably had a nice like two hour
eating asmr
yeah it's just a lot of like chewing
walls slowest mukbang
oh yeah guys i'm exhausted from eating
so much yeah yeah i actually
stopped i want like a proper meal so
let's just go do that alright guys
thanks for enjoying this
strange episode we'll get back to your
regular schedule program soon but in the
meantime
have a good one bye stop eating them
no i don't like it
[Music]
you